salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien dans cette vidéo c'est
l'épisode 3 de ma série documentaire sur
Ragnar le Breton comme la semaine
dernière je vous conseille fortement
d'aller voir les deux premiers épisodes
parce que sinon je pense que vous allez
rater plein de détails et pas comprendre
toute l'histoire que j'essaie de
raconter au travers de cette série et
pour les plus impatients à la fin de cet
épisode je rappelle aussi que
l'intégralité de la série est disponible
sur l'App de brut voilà j'en dis pas
plus bon visionnage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a des trucs qui me donnent des
frissons des fois quand je regarde des
combats quand même ils sont ils sont
hors d'eux ils sortent d'eux ils sont le
ils sont en état second tu vois
moi ce que j'aime c'est voir l'homme se
transformer
c'est les sensations uniques ça date un
shooter d'adrénaline de ouf tu vois
j'ai une admiration profonde pour eux
j'ai envie de le ressentir ça j'ai pas
envie d'être le connard sur son fauteuil
qui dit oh il aurait dû faire ça alors
diversifi tu vois ce que ça fait
légèrement petit carnet puis je me
mettrai ma petite croix je dirais je
l'ai fait tu vois
moi ça me choque un combattant
professionnel qui a ton parcours
qui a peur d'un mec qui est sur Youtube
comme tu dis un tik toker je me suis
sacrifié tu vois j'ai attrapé les
staphylocoques je me suis fissuré la
mâchoire je me suis luxé l'épaule j'ai
pris des coups dans la gueule j'ai
maigri j'ai morflé regarde la gueule que
j'ai on dirait un Polonais qui manque de
sucre
[Musique]
le chemin va être long je te le dis mon
Charlie tôt il va falloir qu'on
s'accroche
la remise en état physique va être hyper
dur c'est ça qui va être le plus
compliqué
parce que je pars quand même de très
très loin ça fait des années que je suis
une actif je suis des très grosses
blessures au niveau des genoux j'ai deux
ligaments croisés du là ici là
après je suis là tout le long
j'ai cassé la main ici plusieurs fois
j'ai les pots j'ai le dos
si on peut attendre un petit peu
parce que j'aime bien mon nez en droit
il est long hein
5h20 j'étais en essayage après j'ai
tourné tout
obligé je rentre chez moi
allez on y va
aller loin d'abord cherche à aller vite
ok passe moins de temps
[Musique]
tu souffres un peu j'arrive
ah franchement je me sens
tout le corps
sont des zones du corps qui se réveille
c'est un truc de ouf
plante ce décor c'est premier combat
professionnel à Arès Fighting
Championship qui est la plus grosse
organisation de France donc c'est comme
si moi demain je dis à Charles je vais
faire du football et je vais jouer au
PSG match contre l'OM et Ragnar c'est ça
qui s'entraînent aujourd'hui et qui
combattent à Arès parce que le gars qui
va être en face de Ragnar il va vouloir
lui arracher la tête mais de la vitesse
à la montée 4 une vraie différence de
vitesse 5 plus fort
ta mère la [__] c'est horrible ce sport
de merde là
et tu poses
psychologiquement c'est dur de
voir que j'en suis là quoi disons j'ai
eu les enfants pas de famille le travail
le machin le corps il s'est endormi en
fait
c'est là que je vis avec ma petite
famille et tout
ça fait longtemps voilà ça commence 10
ans
cette ville cette ville incroyable
tu connais pas Hébreux non mais c'est
une ville où il y a beaucoup de
champions qui sont ici qui ont grandi
ici Ousmane Dembélé
ou pas mécano l'équipe de France midi
Gomis Joseph Gomis tu vois
Sheryfa Luna et de là aussi ça il y a
plein de gens d'ici là qui ont réussi
dans cette ville là
on aurait fait les voir les
gitans et les gitans aussi
tout le monde se connaît ici c'est une
petite ville tout le monde se connaît
dans cette ville une fois il y a un mec
il a proposé une voiture volée au mec à
qui il a brûlé la voiture
[Musique]
à la belle-mère habite là à droite
et c'est la première fois de ma vie que
je reste longtemps dans une ville comme
ça comme j'ai toujours bougé moi droite
à gauche toi j'ai pas eu le temps
d'avoir de
comment dire d'attache
en particulier donc là je suis content
de
routine je suis tranquille toi j'aime
bien
[Musique]
j'ai grandi dans plusieurs milieux
sociaux différents j'étais au port Boyer
à Nantes
c'est un espèce de quartier un peu
populaire très sympathique tout le monde
était un peu comme un niveau que ce soit
socialement parlant
il a grandi dans tous les milieux tu
vois il a fréquenté genre on va dire des
Turcs des Africains des Maghrébins des
des Français tout et au final la
conclusion c'est que on est certes on
est tous différents tu vois on a nos
cultures machin et tout mais au final on
est tous humains avant toute chose et on
a tous besoin de rigoler surtout tu vois
et avec Mathias tu peux être qui tu veux
tu peux être challenge tu peux être
français tu peux être comme je t'ai dit
tout chinois n'importe qui ben avec
Mathias tu vas rigoler tu vas taper une
barre avec lui c'est sûr et certain tu
vois c'est comme ça
on est avec chérie d'origine donc
musulman lui c'est les sports de combat
200 % des blagues de cul t'oublie
moi il est à table des fois avec moi
machin et tout
lâche des grands croisés
[Musique]
John café on appelle Thor et pas pour la
coupe de cheveux
[Rires]
mon piner
tu vois ça ils sont complètement
différents mais il s'entendent bien
parce qu'il se respecte et c'est ça la
France donc bon ramadan à tous et BFM TV
va te faire [__]
comment tu as rencontré Mathias
la première fois de ma vie que je l'ai
vu c'était
à la mosquée c'était une prière de
vendredi et je vois arriver
un grand Blondin avec les cheveux
attachés comme ça à l'arrière et j'ai
cru que c'était une suédois on commence
à dire scandinave c'est sûr et tout
l'autre colique tu vois ouais je crois
que c'est reconverti
norvégien au Suédois comme ça et tout il
avait quel âge 18 19 ans on avait on
était à peine majeur je pense
moi aussi je fais vider tout ça et donc
le lendemain je travaille en boîte de
nuit
je le vois arriver le sujet
alors mosquée tu vois donc ça va et toi
et je voyais parle en français et il me
dit pas il me dit
il me dit pas je suis français
avec lui je pense pas trop de choses
avec moi c'était un bosniaque avec une
autre c'était un Kabyle avec un autre
c'était polonais avec l'autre c'était le
fils caché de Vladimir Poutine
[Musique]
et les jours il mentait beaucoup
à Paris il sortait et genre il se
faisait passer pour un gars de football
américain machin ah ouais non il en est
il en a eu un des des gros moments de
mythomanie il y en a eu un paquet
j'étais mythomane j'étais violent
j’étais un escroc j'étais
une saloperie dégueulasse quoi j'en ai
vraiment je mentais pour camoufler ce
que j'étais vraiment
tu vois j'ai toujours menti dans ça
je me suis toujours inventé des vies par
rapport à ça parce que je me suis dit si
les gens ils savent vraiment
qui je suis vraiment ils m'aimeront pas
j'avais honte de qui j'étais et l'osait
pas trop en parler de
d'où il venait qu'est-ce qu'il avait
vécu
et après on le connaissant devenant
petit à petit tu vois mon frérot en fait
il s'est confié c'est là que tu apprends
en fait que il est passé par des moments
difficiles tu vois dans son enfance et
tout après m'a parlé du foyer quand
est-ce que tu as été foyer toi
[Musique]
je l'adore cette photo
je vais raconter une bêtise quand même
[Musique]
à cet âge là il était tout bon dehors
avec Mémé et ma mère et apprenez à faire
du jardinage
on arrivait la semaine des fois on
restait un mois pendant les grandes
vacances on partait souvent se balader
marcher au bord de la mer aller pêcher
les promenades en ville quand tu vois on
allait acheter un catalogue à la
librairie les acheter un petit jeu de
temps en temps on allait se promener à
la plage c'est des souvenirs tu vois
chercher ça et c'était tout comme
j'avais de toutes les couleurs et
ramasser ça ah oui vous allez faire ça
aussi
ma grand-mère je me réveillais je
m'étais Bruce Lee je me l'avais bon ça
dedans je remettais Bruce Lee j'allais
jouer dehors je m'étais Bruce Lee je
l'aime acheter un nunchaku et tout c'est
compliqué
[Musique]
santé
ultra méga aimé tu vois de ressentir ça
quand tu es petit c'est magnifique ça a
toujours toujours aidé toujours gâté
toujours protégé tu reparti
au clash quand vous voyez des choses qui
allaient pas tu vois nous a toujours
beaucoup protégé ma grand-mère moi il
m'a dit que vous voyez un peu comme ça
deuxième maman
je suis
un grand mais vous avez une maman
à 200 mètres quitter leur rond-point à
la première sortie et continuer à suivre
la rue rue Parmentier
maintenant à droite puis quitter le rang
[Musique]
primaire
avec des jumeaux que ça fait Mustafa et
Kader
ici
franchement
on était bien
c'est quoi la pire bêtise que tu as fait
la pire bêtise que j'ai fait en primaire
je me fais une poubelle ouais en
primaire
si j'ai toujours été le plus con dans
tout ce que j'ai fait j'ai toujours été
très con ça à l'école primaire au
collège et si j'en fais que des
conneries tu vois c'était vraiment je
mordais les gens je me battais tout le
temps à l'école
j'étais le cassos de l'école quoi tu
vois
math il a pas eu de grosses crises
d'adolescence de c'est on va dire 15 à
18 19 par contre après que là ça a été
ça a été très particulier
[Musique]
tu as une adolescence difficile quitte à
aussi à amené à la délinquance j'étais
un garçon qui a fait des conneries
je suis monté sur des vols à armés je
suis monté sur
[Musique]
des sur des cambriolages je suis monté
sur des trucs à la con comme ça tu vois
j'étais un bon voleur
les gens tu vois on a braqué une
bijouterie avec des bijoux à 50 balles
c'était vraiment un truc de mon gars
on est arrivé on a pris le truc on était
content après on comptait regarder les
bagues ça va se rendre en une tonne on
essaie de la revendre personne n'en
voulait
et vraiment un truc de merde mais
vraiment les gangsters
avec quelqu'un qui était ensemble il
trouvait toujours
j'ai pas eu il trouvait toujours une une
on va dire une raison pour se battre tu
vois
90% c'était de sa faute c'est ça le pire
tu vois c'était jamais la faute tu vois
j'aime bien faire le blanc un peu
instable attention
en équipe comme ça avec des têtes cramé
tu vois
[Musique]
je vais bien ce truc là je me la
raconter c'était ridicule en vrai
mais j'aime mieux prétention de vouloir
faire carrière dans 10 quoi c'est
vraiment pas du tout je me serais fait
massacrer au bout de deux semaines
j'ai pas du tout fait pour ça quoi
parce qu'en fait moi j'étais sportif à
côté je faisais du basket
mais à côté je faisais des crapuleries
j'étais
je me retrouvais avec des gens
qui avaient pas le même mode de vie que
moi en fait à la finale je me disais on
est pareil mais en fait on n'est pas
pareil moi j'ai toujours envie de faire
du théâtre de faire rire les gens tu
vois de faire des trucs comme ça tu vois
c'était destiné à faire que ça de leur
vie tu vois ça veut dire moi j'ai des
potes c'est encore au placard là
ça fait 10 ans ils ont fait des évasions
ils sont ressortis c'est des cauchemars
les mecs tu vois moi je suis pas comme
ça toute son enfance a été jusqu'à un
certain âge des bagarres des machins des
trucs c'est pas compliqué si tu as connu
la violence dans ton enfance tu vas le
reproduire
[Musique]
avec notre communauté par exemple
regarde on a vécu des guerres des trucs
horribles et tout comment je suis arrivé
en France par exemple quand tu es jeune
on discutait pas tu vois quand il y
avait des gens parlaient pas la langue
c'était compliqué mais dès qu'il y avait
un truc au collège je crois en France on
va pas tu vois on frappe pas à la
moindre chez nous c'est normal en fait
tu vois donc on reproduisait cette
violence et pour nous c'était normal et
on se faisait virer du collège tu vois
et ça arrivait une deux fois on a
compris que c'était pas comme ça donc on
a essayé de s'adapter on s'adapter tu
vois
[Musique]
on est des réfugiés politiques tu vois
on est on a échappé à la guerre pour
survivre en vérité tu vois on est juste
venu ici pour pour vivre tu vois pour
retrouver la vie tu vois et il a vu ça
en fait tu vois je pense qu'il voyait ça
lui de ses yeux et de son de par son
vécu tu vois
[Musique]
vraiment très mobile voilà j'ai voilà
[Applaudissements]
si je rentre tout de suite
je pense que ça va être une thérapie
pour moi
quelques petits trucs que j'ai en moi
[Applaudissements]
comme s'ils se faire peut-être prendre
des coups de poings ça va peut-être je
sais pas ça va peut-être me faire du
bien je pense
[Applaudissements]
mais du coup ça m'intéresse d'avoir
votre avis sur le combat ça le regarde
pas
j'aurais préféré qu'il le fasse pas je
dis que c'est quoi pour toi je dis c'est
pas une thérapie par hasard il me dit
oui
c'était l'idée de se dire j'ai envie de
faire un combat et voir où ça va me
mener
c'est vraiment une mission compliquée
pour lui
pour être très honnête c'est quasiment
mission impossible
[Musique]
c'est peut-être une thérapie parce que
vous pensez qu'il y a une blessure
j'aimerais bien la connaître
lui il parle de son passé
[Musique]
j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu le
dernier de l'épisode final sortira la
semaine prochaine vendredi à 18h sur la
chaîne Youtube de brut si vous voulez le
voir il est déjà disponible dans l'app
de brut merci encore pour votre soutien
à très vite